divulgación de difamación con impacto en
el prestigio del país el agro ciudad
alta promover la indisciplina social
peligrosidad muy alta son algunos de los
incidentes tipificados como delitos en
la primera ley de ciberseguridad de cuba
son en total 17 delitos que van desde la
propagación de noticias falsas hasta el
terrorismo o la ciberguerra a mí me
parece que eso es algo en contra de de
la libertad de expresión de cada cual
me entiendes y en otros países lo hacen
no sé por qué aquí no nos lo prohíben me
parece que eso está mal un texto que
para el gobierno se trata de un marco
legal en un territorio que dio la
bienvenida el internet móvil apenas en
2018 y esta resolución de nuestro
ministerio lo que establece es ir a la
posibilidad o amplía la posibilidad de
trabajar ante cualquier incidente debe
sin excesiva seguridad pero desde human
rightswatch de la mano de su director
para las américas josé miguel vivanco
crítica en que la ley restringe el
acceso a internet
y es que la norma llega a poco más de un
mes después de unas protestas en las que
miles de personas marcharon en rechazo
al gobierno consideradas como una de las
manifestaciones más importantes en los
últimos años dichas movilizaciones
terminaron con un muerto decenas de
heridos y cientos de arrestados además
de un apagón del internet durante cinco
días
esta ley entra en vigor una semana
después de que el senado de eeuu
respaldar al gobierno de washington para
que prestará servicios de internet a la
isla algo que el ejecutivo cubano
califica como una injerencia